foreign
so drag strip mode the first thing it
does is you can hear the cooling fans
running in the background it cools the
drive units as much as possible because
they make the most power when they're
coolest in addition to that we warm the
battery pack up just a little bit just
to get it into its Optimum range for
performance
then when you pull up to the line we
have what's called cheetah stunts where
you hold your foot firmly on the brake
and then you stand on the gas pedal and
the car will enter launch mode you'll
feel it squat because it applies power
to the motors and then the front of the
car will lower down towards the ground
what this does is it pre-loads the car
low and it improves front axle traction
so that when you launch instead of the
front of the car coming up and you lose
traction off the front wheels it
actually holds the front of the car down
as you accelerate and gives you better
grip all the way through the zero to 60.